hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast bacteria that eat electricity
understanding bio cathodes using culture
independent techniques it is presented
by Brian Eadie PhD a research biologist
at the Center for biomolecular science
and engineering at the Naval Research
Laboratory I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located in the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Eddie I will
now turn the presentation over to him hi
and thank you for giving me a chance to
talk to you today about bacteria they
need electricity and about the ways that
we're trying to understand how they're
able to do it so they'll start off with
electron transfer is life so all living
things use electron transfer reactions
in order to generate electricity or
generate energy and to generate biomass
so everything that we're familiar with
are the animals and things like that
we're familiar with like elephants and
butyric acid bacteria use reduced
electron donors like carbohydrates in
order to provide electrons which then
they transfer to an electron acceptor
and this diagram here oxygen in other
organisms they'll use other things such
as nitrate or sulfate or iron oxides or
in some cases organic molecules as the
electron acceptors and then there are
other organisms like trees and any
photosynthetic organisms that are able
to use electrons from water and then
energy from light in order to reduce
carbon dioxide and make more biomass and
make more organic matter and the reason
that we're interested in this today is
because there are some bacteria that are
able to use extra cellular electron
donors Aurel extra electron acceptors so
in our case we use oxygen as an electron
acceptor and that's something that we we
breathe in and it's inside of our cells
and that's an internal electron acceptor
but there are bacteria that are able to
actually transfer the electrons from
inside their cell to the outside to an
electrode that's called an anode that
acts as an electron sink and then there
are other organisms that are able to use
what is called a cathode in order to
accept electrons from that cathode and
then they put you're basically pulling
electrons out of the cathode and what
we're interested in in the Navy in this
case is how these organisms are able to
do that
and how we might be able to use that in
order to look at things like bio
corrosion or microbial fuel cells and
we've got a keen interest in using
synthetic biology in order to try and
make better organisms to do these things
for us and it comes down to the
beginning the the Navy was mostly
interested in microbial fuel cells from
a power generation perspective because
these are things that can be used as
long-term stable power sources that
would be able to supply energy for
instruments and things like that now so
these the pictures that I show on the
screen here are this is a buoy on the
right that most
holding some instruments that was being
powered by a microbial fuel cell that
was buried in the sediment and this
lasted for around a year until a
hurricane came along and wiped it out
but it was the first proof of principle
that you can power a sensor array for a
long period of time using just bacteria
and whatever they're able to find to eat
and from this then we've also started
looking at how how organisms are able to
use the cathode in order to live so we
actually took in an electrode from one
of those microbial fuel cells and then
some additional seawater and some
sediment and used it to inoculate a
culture that then has been transferred
dozens of times since then
I was initially brought into the lab in
2009 and has been maintained since then
and this is a bacterial community that's
been growing on here that is very robust
it's been shift around the country to
other collaborators to work with and
it's transferable we can just keep
scraping it off and put it on to a new
electrode and it will grow and what's
really interesting about it is that one
of the organisms in there is autotrophic
so it's able to use the electrons from
the cathode to fix carbon dioxide and
then it's feeding the rest of the
bacteria that are there the key thing
here is that only a few of the bacteria
that are growing here are actually
things that we've been able to cultivate
in a pure ultra in the lab and one of
the ones that we haven't been able to
grow is the autotrophs so we've been
using some culture independent methods
to try and understand how it's able to
do that and our goals are to try and
understand extracellular electron
transfer from a very fundamental level
so previously a lot of work has gone
into the engineering aspect of things so
what can we do to make the electrodes
different so that bacteria will be able
to grow better using them and what we're
interested in is specifically how the
bacteria are using their proteins in
order to grow so that we can try and
improve things from that side of things
and like I said before
one of the things we really are
interested in in synthetic biology and
what we're trying to do here is find
some chassis organisms that we can put
components into and then find components
to put into them that are going to be
more environmentally relevant that will
actually grow in seawater
today most synthetic biology has been
done in e.coli which does not grow very
well in seawater and so we're trying to
make things that would be more relevant
for the Navy and like I said we don't
have cultivated isolates of some of
these organisms and that presents some
challenges compared to how most
microbiology has been done in the past
so what we're trying to do is understand
how a community is growing when we can't
bring the the individual parts into the
lab separate we have to study them all
together and so what we're trying to do
is go from that slimy muck on an
electrode to nice clean models of what
electrons are doing in organisms and to
kind of step back and look at things
from a very high perspective here the
way we're doing this is we're looking at
part of what's called the central dogma
of biology so for everything that's
alive there are these four things that
are the the genome which is made up of
DNA the transcriptome which is made up
of RNA the proteome which is made up of
protein and in the biochemistry that is
occurring in in life and some of these
things like the genome and the
transcriptome we can actually measure
very precisely with a very high
throughput and with relatively few
biases although there are still some
biases there however things like the
proteome are a lot harder to measure to
really get a good idea of what's going
on with every protein in the organism
and biochemistry it's really not
possible at all to study that you had a
very high throughput way so we're
focusing on the
meta-genome or the genome and the
transcriptome of these organisms and the
way that we're doing this is with meta
omics so this is basically looking at
all of the
Genomes in a community and all of the
transcriptomes in a community at the
same time and what we're learning from
the metagenomics is what genes are in
this community and and what things this
community might be able to do so we can
look at genes that are known from other
organisms and say these organisms that
we see in the community may be doing
ammonia oxidation or they may be doing
nitrate respiration then we can look at
the meta transcriptomics and see which
of these organisms that were there in
the meta genome are actually active and
we can see which genes are active then
how do they change expression depending
on what the growth conditions are now
we've also got people other people in
the center not me doing proteomics and
metabolomics and meta metabolomics
trying to look at communities using
these techniques and they're very
important but they're a lot harder to do
and there are a lot other a lot there's
a lot of things that you have missed
when you look at it that way and then
we're also working with isolates trying
to pull out individual organisms because
that's where you can end up getting the
most fine resolution of your data and
then obviously you need to have an
isolate in order to do a lot of the
manipulations that that we want to do
and so to start off with we're gonna
look at metagenomics and I know there
are other metagenomics talks in this
meeting so I'm not going to go into too
much detail here but basically the way
this works is you have a community you
sample its DNA and then you do
sequencing which gives you millions and
millions of short reads which by
themselves aren't very useful but then
you can take them and you can assemble
them into larger contiguous sequences or
contexts and in some cases even an
entire genome and then that gives you a
better idea of which organisms are there
their relative abundance which ones are
very abundant which ones are very rare
and in some cases you can get some other
information from that and so what we're
trying to do here is again just look at
which genes are present in this
community and what might this community
be able to do and so with our data we
started off with kind of a first pass
looking at a single sample which makes
it harder to pull out individual genomes
but we were still able to group these
sequences after we'd assembled them into
what looked like 15 to 20 different
organism dens and in this community we
were able to identify our almost 80,000
genes total which is a whole lot of data
and we're trying to sort through that
and then trying to look at which
components we were interested in but
then we also had more more data that was
coming in and then we ended up rebidding
everything with a our biological
replicates and then this really gave us
some very good bends so we had 16 bends
of genomes that were almost completely
complete and one of these in particular
was really interesting so this is the
one that's in red here and that was
initially identified as an unclassified
chrome acha and that is a it's a group
of bacteria they're they're known as a
purple sulfur bacteria although a lot of
them are purple and a lot of them don't
actually use sulfur but they are there
are some representatives in there there
are autotrophic so that immediately was
a key finding so we were really
interested in it and when we looked in
the rest of the meta-genome we see that
this is really the only organism that
looks like it's an autotroph but then it
also has some genes that are also found
in iron oxidizers which we hypothesize
would be an analogue of the kind of
metabolism we are looking at because
those are bacteria they're able to take
iron that's outside the cell and then
take electrons off of it and then grow
using the energy we can get from that
and so we wanted to look at this
organism in a little bit more detail and
then I should also say that about the
time that we finally got these good bins
out of this we submitted some some DNA
to PacBio because they were interested
in assembling metagenomes from using
sequencing from their sequencers and
they got back to us a couple of weeks
later with a complete genome from this
organism that we had spent the last year
trying to assemble
but you're using that we could be very
confident that we didn't do a good job
of assembling and that all the genes
that we thought were in there are
actually in there and then using those
genes we could go through and look to
see where it fits in in the Tree of Life
and one of the interesting things we
found from this is that if you just look
at the 16s ribosomal RNA gene or 23's
also you get very different picture of
what kind of organism it is then if you
look at the whole genome itself and so
if you just look at the 16s it looks
like it's a member of the crummy
shayla's which I talked about before is
the purple sulfur bacteria however if
you look at the whole genome it looks
like it's more closely aligned with the
thigh of Hercules which are a different
group of bacteria that is also some of
them are our autotrophic but they're
they're not photosynthetic and recently
just a couple of weeks ago there was
another paper that came out using the
the whole genome technique that has
reclassified them as a separate order
they're still within the gamma
Proteobacteria but they are now separate
from both of that Achilles and from HCl
YZ so this is a really interesting new
organism that so far no one had found
and then actually in the last few years
more and more people have been finding
it now that they're able to put this 16s
gene that they're finding in the
environment with this organism and be
able to tell that it's not a member of
the crew machines it's something else
entirely and so one of the other things
we wanted to look at is just where in
the bio cathode biofilm this thing is
growing so to do that we use
fluorescence in situ hybridization which
is also called fish to specifically
label each of these organisms based upon
their 16s or 23s ribosomal RNA sequence
and from this we can see there's a clump
in this slide you can see that is
labeled as Caminada stand area
electrified
which is the autotrophic organism and it
the the probe itself is green but when
it's mixed with the blue from the
gaddafi which is a DNA stain that stains
everything and the red which stains
gamma Proteobacteria which this organism
also has those all combine to make this
kind of orangish whitish color which is
very confusing because then the Alpha
proteobacteria which are a completely
different group of bacteria are also
orange but if you look at the individual
individual colors with this microscope
you can pull out then this clump that's
labeled here is actually thinned area
while the others are not so it forms a
patchy biofilm in this case it's not a
very dense one and other electrodes that
I've looked at it it does get more dense
but one of the things that's really
interesting about the fact that if so
patchy is that if we look at electrical
conductivity we see a very highly
conductive biofilm so this is work that
was done by my colleague Matt Yates and
what he's doing is using what's called
an inter digitated electrode array or an
ID a to look at the conductivity from
one electrode to another so on the left
side of the slide you see a diagram of
what these ideas are the basically two
cone-shaped electrodes that are mixed
together kind of like you know inter
digitated there might stick your fingers
between each other but there's a very
defined gap of five micrometers between
these two electrodes and these form a
single Spath that goes back and forth
that's always five micrometers apart and
the whole path is 13 millimeters long
which gives you a very long gap this way
and then he's measuring the conductivity
of electricity between those two
electrodes across this 5 micrometer gap
by so he's measuring the different
potentials by holding a yeah so there's
a source and a drain electrode and you
one at a slightly higher potential so
that electrons will flow from the source
to the drain and then as he changes the
the median potential of those two
electrodes going from high to low and
then back you can actually see that at
very low potentials
there's no conductivity but as the
potential increases then you get
conductivity and a peak of around five
hundred and fifty millivolts and if you
look at the the total conductivity
it's a verage over what we think is the
size of the the biofilm on here you
actually see that it's as conductive as
a Geo vector biofilm and and these are
some some bacteria they've been studied
for a long time they're thought to make
one of the most highly conductive
biofilms it's out there so it's very
interesting that this the Apache biofilm
is as conductive as that and we're still
working on trying to do this in a way to
get a little bit more information about
that and then another thing using these
ideas one of the interesting things we
can do here is only poised one of the
bands so these organisms can only grow
if we give them electrons at a certain
potential and if we only set one of
these electrode arrays at that potential
then they're only able to grow on one of
them so you can see on the left there
arrows that are pointing to bands that
were poised and then on the right are
bands that were not poised so the sand
area is only able to grow on the ones
where we're actually feeding them
electrons at the right potential and as
the biofilm grows eventually that it
spreads out enough that it makes a
connection with the unvoiced bands and
then those actually have their poise
that the right potential also for things
to grow on them and then you can start
this little bit of growth there so
looking back at this organism tend area
this is the one organism in the biofilm
it's actually able to fix carbon dioxide
and then it also has genes from iron
oxides and bacteria that make it look
I can perform extracellular electron
transfer and so if we look at the the
co2 fixation pathway this is using the
the Calvin Benson Basham cycle which is
actually the same cycle that plants use
and cyanobacteria use but it's also
found in a lot of other bacteria and
what's particularly interesting about
this organism is that it has two of
these Rubisco so it has one the form 1aq
which is normally thought to be adapted
for a high carbon dioxide and low oxygen
environment and then another which is
the one AC Rubisco which is adapted for
a high oxygen low carbon dioxide
environment and so the 1aq is somewhat
less efficient than the one AC but the
one AC has a much higher overhead so it
requires a lot more proteins because it
actually forms these car boxes own
shells which concentrate the the Rubisco
and concentrate carbon dioxide in the
same spot so that it can be more
efficient and and that'll come in a
little bit later and then the other
thing to point out here is that the
reductant for this co2 fixation pathway
is NADPH and we'll talk a little bit
more about thermodynamics in just a
minute but while I'm on the subject here
I also wanted to say that we have these
proteins in here that are able to do
that we think would be able to do
extracellular of electron transfer or
eet so we've got some that look like the
psyche 2 which is the figure on the left
the far-left
complex there is the the cytochrome C 2
or psych 2 and then we also have some
multi heme cytochromes with a pauran
that it's located near them in the in
the genome which look like it may be
able to do things similar to what you
see on the in the figure on the right so
these are the ones that we think are the
most likely to be involved in getting
electrons inside the cell but we have
yet to actually prove that so to get
into
in the very basics of the thermodynamics
here one of the things that this
organism has to be able to do in order
to grow is make the reducing equivalents
or the nadh or NADPH in order to fix co2
and the challenge here is that we're
giving them electrons at 310 millivolts
and they somehow need to do this
reduction reaction that is at minus 320
millivolts so somehow they've got to get
energy to drive this reaction in Reverse
in the way they do that is likely to be
a reverse electron transfer so what
happens then is we have electrons coming
in at 310 millivolts and then going
through the forward direction to
cytochrome the CVB oxidase which is
generating a proton gradient then is
used in order to drive the reaction in
Reverse and we'll talk a little bit more
about this a later but I wanted to
introduce that now because it's gonna be
kind of key understanding some of the
data later so right now I'm gonna start
talking more about the meta
transcriptomics of of this community and
so what we're interested in from this is
basically what organisms are active and
which genes are being used and this
gives us an idea of what this community
is trying to do and we're gonna look at
two different conditions to see how what
it's trying to do changes depending on
what the condition is so what why we're
using meta transcriptomics is if we go
back to the central dogma of life there
are different control points within this
chain where you can stop or start the
next step in order to control how things
are gonna happen and the easiest place
to start and stop something is right at
the beginning so we stopped it right
after we basically stopped the formation
of the mRNA that would be then used to
make proteins and then this lets us look
at which genes are being used because we
can look at how much of each specific
RNA is present within the cell and then
we can look at how the
the level or the amount of RNA for each
gene changes depending on what growth
conditions were using and the way that
that we're doing this is we're using the
the meta genome that we have and we're
aligning the RNA seek data to that in
order to see which genes are being used
and I know this is a very complex figure
but the main thing to take away from
this is that you know as we we take the
data from the meta-genome we take the
data from the meta transcriptome and
then we're combining them and we're
looking at the activity of the
individual members of the community and
then looking at the activity of the
different genes in order to get an idea
what's happening and to do this we're
using this kind of paired electrode
design so we are growing this we're
growing four of these electrodes up and
then we're measuring cyclic voltammetry
to make sure that everything
electrochemically looks normal and then
we're switching two of those electrodes
from the the optimal potential which is
310 millivolts versus a standard
hydrogen electrode or in this case and
the figure that's on the right here I've
got it against a silver chloride
electrode or where it's 0.1 this is all
just it's relative to a reference
electrode so I normally just use the
standard hydrogen electrode but this so
we change one of them or we leave one
set of reactors at 310 millivolts and
then we change two of them to 470
millivolts which is a much less
favorable potential for them to grow
because they get less energy from the
oxygen reduction reaction which is at
810 millivolts and it takes them more
energy in order to get the reducing
equivalents they need for co2 fixation
so it makes it a lot harder for them to
grow when we put them at the higher
potential and then we we harvest the
electrodes for RNA and and then sequence
it and
then we actually repeated this again a
couple of weeks later to get four more
reactors so we have basically two
reactors at each of two potentials and
each to an ocular so put two by two by
two and so then if we look at which
organisms have the most RNA total in
these reactors we can actually see that
tend area is the most active organism
that's it's in our reactors and this is
really interesting because if we just
look at the DNA it only makes up around
a quarter of the DNA but then if we look
at the the messenger RNA it's around
three-quarters of the messenger RNA and
the other organisms some of them Marino
bacter and laprincia which here are in
green and blue are more abundant based
upon the DNA but then less abundant
based upon the the RNA so this is this
is particularly interesting because we
think that tend area is the organism
that's feeding everybody else so it has
to be the most active in order for
everything else to be able to grow and
then we can also look at how the
percentage of effectivity intend area is
correlated with the amount of current
being generated so even though this is a
relatively reproducible bacterial
community there's still a lot of
variability so our elect are our
reactors will range from around 10
millivolts to around 50 millivolt or
milliamps sorry 10 milliamps to 50
milliamps depending on just how things
shake out and how the community develops
but if we look at the percentage of tend
area within that community we actually
see that there is this correlation
between a community that has more tend
area and a community that's making more
electricity so this was another thing
that's supporting the idea that tinned
area is the organism that's actually
transferring the electricity or
transferring the electrons from the
electrode if we look at some of the
other bacteria that are in the community
we actually see a negative or
no correlation with the amount of
currents generated and yeah so even
though this is only based on not for
reactors for each potential if we look
at the the electrodes or the reactors
that we did for the meta-genome also if
we look at the DNA the relative
abundance of the DNA within the
community we also see this same trend
where the reactors that are making more
current are also more enriched for tend
area so your total that ends up being
something like 16 reactors so it's a
pretty good number of replicas oh if we
focus in still on 10th area here we're
looking at the individual gene come our
protein complexes and groups of genes
that perform a specific type of
metabolism and one of the things that
came out of this is that if we look at
the co2 fixation genes in particular one
of the things we see is when there's
more energy available so when we have
them at the optimal potential then we
see a higher relative abundance of the
genes for co2 fixation and then we also
see this form 1a hue Rubisco which is
the one that's less efficient but faster
and then a few of the other blue I guess
gene modules that we see here are things
for glycogen formation which is
basically a storage product the pentose
phosphate cycle which is part of the
central carbon metabolism so this is one
of the bits of metabolism that basically
makes all the things that make up a cell
if we look at the genes that are more
highly expressed at the suboptimal
potential we see the genes for this form
one AC Rubisco which is the more
efficient but higher overhead one and
then also the carboxy zone that's that
this fits in there so this is suggesting
that this potential there they're
actually trying to be more efficient
even though it's it's going to be a less
fast way to grow so we can also go
through and look at individual I guess
chunks of the electron transport chain
and look at how they change their
expression depending on what potential
the community is grown at and so we see
a few groups here where the top we have
genes that are more highly expressed at
the higher potential or the suboptimal
potential and then down at the bottom we
have some genes that are more highly
expressed at the optimal potential and
we can kind of form some hypotheses
based upon which genes these are and how
they're used so you know the the high
potential genes a lot of these so we
have the the psych 2 which is going to
be involved in getting electrons into
the cell and then we have some of these
genes that are going to be at the in the
forward electron transport chain and
then down here in the middle I am what's
labeled as the ret chain or the reverse
electron transfer chain and these are
the genes that are going to be involved
in and basically generating and reducing
equivalents and one of the things we see
here is that they don't really change
their expression very much at all so it
seems kind of like this is being how
stable while the things on the right
side of that electron transport chain
are what's actually being buried and and
so what kind of comes out of this is
that there are actually multiple routes
for electron transfer within this
organism and within this so this this
diagram here is is also based upon a lot
of work that people have been doing an
iron oxide from bacteria and looking at
genes that are shared between iron
oxidizing bacteria and tinned area in
order to get an idea of which ones might
be I use for this and then we also
looked at the how they change expression
depending on the potential here and what
we see is it looks like we have
basically they on the the right side and
then the box it's labeled terminal
oxidase we see the set of genes here
that's labeled CCO Fastow saya and this
is one of the terminal oxidases that
would actually be reducing oxygen and
generating a proton motive or proton
gradient then would be used for energy
by the cell and so here I'm just gonna
kind of summarize what we've talked
about so far and then we're gonna go on
to talk a little bit more about some of
the energetics within this community so
so far what we found is that tend area
looks to be the keystone organism so
it's it's autotrophic it's changing its
activity depending on the potential it's
changing the expression of genes
depending on what potential we're
growing it at and it's it's very
abundant it so know one of the things we
don't really know yet also at this point
is what role some of the other organisms
there in this community are going to be
playing and then that might be a good
question for later is to you know what
what these other things are doing so
we're gonna look at now is how these
potential routes for electron transport
might be used and we're gonna look at
how we might be able to use some of this
apart and so the way we're going to be
doing this is with these specific
metabolic inhibitors so these will block
a particular part of each of these
chains and from that we can kind of
start to pull out what these things are
doing and so this is a very old idea
people have been using these inhibitors
for 40 or 50 years in order to block a
particular thing and they've been used
in order to provide some of the first
evidence for the reverse electron
transfer or in this case it's called
uphill electron transfer and that's
basically what we're trying to do here
and so what we're looking at is the
electron flux through each of these
potential routes so now we've got on
this slide I'm showing four different
inhibitors sorry so on this line showing
four different inhibitors and each of
these is gonna block a specific part and
then using the Nernst equation we can
actually kind of predict how much
electron flow we're gonna see through
both the forward and reverse
so this equation basically lets us look
at the potential of electrons of the
electron transfer reaction from the
cathode to the cell itself and then the
electron transfer from the terminal
oxidase to oxygen which is going to be
at around 816 millivolts for sustained
hydrogen and then also from the cathode
to NADH which is around minus 320 and
then from that we can actually predict
how much how much electron flux we need
to have through each direction of the
pathway based upon the metabolism we
know these cells are doing which is the
co2 fixation reaction and from that we
can calculate that they'll need around
75% of the electrons to go through the
forward pathway and around a quarter at
most to be going through the reverse
electron transfer pathway and so the
first thing we're gonna do here is
basically test that hypothesis using
this inhibitor called CCCP which
collapses the proton gradient so in
order to drive reverse electron transfer
you need to have protons in the
periplasm and what the CCCP does is it
basically grabs onto those protons and
then it can carry them across the
membrane and collapse the gradient so we
think that when we do this what we're
gonna do is basically stop all reverse
electron transfer but we think there may
be some increase then from the
cytochrome C oxidase that may actually
counterbalance a little bit of that
and when we we do this we actually see
that we get this immediate drop in
current if you look at the graph on the
left um I guess I should point out here
also that when I refer to drop them in a
drop in the absolute value of the
magnitude of the current so because this
is a cathode it's pulling electrons off
we are recording the the current as
being negative just not because of you
know it's kind of the arbitrary way that
we look at electron transfer so it it
looks like it's an increase in current
mean it's actually a drop in the
absolute magnitude of the current so
when I add the CCP what we get is this
immediate drop that ends up being around
25% of the total current and then we get
this much slower increasing or much
slower approach to zero in the current
which we're interpreting as the cells
catching because in in some cases the
attachment of cells is actually ATP
dependent so they need energy in order
to stay attached to the electrode and
the other possibility is that they're
just deciding to leave because you know
if they can't breathe on the electrode
any more than they may as well go
somewhere else and find trying to find a
better place to live either way we see
this immediate drop in current and
what's particularly interesting about
this is that this is also correlated
with the amount of current that they
were generating to begin with
so what we think is happening here is
that under the under conditions where
they're they're basically happier cells
they're able to generate more energy per
electron and thus when we add the CCCP
we get a bigger drop in current so some
of this may be related to the amount of
oxygen that's able to get to the
electrode itself or local pH there may
also be some correlation there with the
amount of biomass if there's too much or
too little there just may not be enough
enough metabolism there in order to keep
things going so then we're moving on and
looking at a few other inhibitors so
instead of just inhibiting the proton
motive force we wanted to inhibit the
specific complexes and so the first of
the the reverse electron transfer
inhibitors we looked at what Santa
Mycenae and what this should do is
inhibit the bc1 complex and what we see
here is a much smaller drop in the
current so this here it's three to eight
percent and one of the problems here is
that when I added it it a lot of it
precipitated so that we may not have
actually been adding and enough or
getting enough of this inhibitor to the
cells in order to block this and we see
the same thing if we look at this other
inhibitor rotenone which inhibits well
it's essentially the complex one in the
bacteria and again we see this three to
eight percent drop in current but we
also had a lot of precipitation so it's
it's hard to really know for sure but
the other the thing that does interest
me about this a lot is that if you add
the two of them together so we added
rotenone and then added anthem Ison and
we see I saw a around five percent drop
when I added wrote known and then I saw
another five percent drop when I added
anthem Ison and I saw the same thing if
I had to anthem Ison first and then so
it looks like there is something
happening there but it's not enough to
completely get rid of it so still need
to work on that a little bit more but
then if we add cyanide this completely
kills the current and and this this
makes a lot of sense because we think
that he's are very critical to
everything that occurs so they're
they're extracellular heme or outer
membrane teams that are required to get
electrons across the membrane
there are periplasmic teams that are
required to get it from the outer to the
inner membrane and then there are teams
and several of the enzymes that are
involved in the membrane bound electron
transport chain and so when we add
cyanide all of these teams get poison
and we see this immediate drop in
current and the reason it doesn't go to
zero completely is that there's actually
a slight offset here so if before I
added any cells to this reactor at all
the current was slightly positive just
because of the way that the there was
some variability
the reference electrodes and I was using
so this is this amount of current that's
generated after we had the heme is
identical to the amount of current that
was generated before I added any cells
to the reactor at all
so from this we've you know using
inhibitors we've been able to get this
real-time data on the electron transfer
processes in this community and the CC
CCCP data gives me a lot of confidence
of model that we're using is actually
correct because we see this as dropping
current that is identical to what we
would have expected and we're still I
need to work a little bit more on the
complex one and the bc1 complex
inhibitors because the precipitation
just isn't allowing us to to see what we
want to see there and this is work that
I'm hoping to be continuing at home in
the next several months here but it's
been kind of pushed to the background
for a while so from here some of the
other things that we're interested in
working with still and are have in
progress is we've got a lot more
sequencing we're doing transcriptomics
on isolates we're doing we're hoping to
do more transcriptomics on other
conditions within the biofilm and trying
to grow the the trying to isolate sind
area still we've been working on that
for years and it just hasn't been
something we've been able to get in pure
culture we're also working very hard on
developing one of the isolates from the
community that it's called Moreno vector
CP one as a chassis for synthetic
biology and we've made a lot of progress
along that front and then where we're
testing some of these component or we'd
like to test on the components we found
with the meta transcriptomics and
metagenomics trying to put them into
other organisms and see if we can
recapitulate this electron transfer
there and so with that I'd like to thank
the the people that I've been working
with particularly Sarah Glavine who was
the pi/4 a lot of this work and was one
who hired me at NRL to begin with and
then
ouch one man was also a COPI I from the
first several years I was at NRL and
then Kirsty Coombs did a lot of the the
reactors for the inhibitor studies Matt
Yates did a lot of the electrochemistry
that I would be happy to answer any
questions you have
Thank You dr. Eddie for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box it appears on your
screen and click the send button our
speaker will follow up with your
questions via email so let's get started
our first question is why do you think
you can't get tinned area into a cure
culture so one of the things that a lot
of iron oxidizing bacteria have a very
high sensitivity to is organic carbon I
am one of the ways that we normally
isolate bacteria is using agarose plates
or for some iron oxidizing bacteria
they'll use iron gradient tubes and when
you are when you autoclave to sterilize
the auger sometimes you can actually
break it up and make some smaller sugars
that then will end up inhibiting some
autotrophic metabolism so that's one
possibility another possibility is that
there's just something that one of the
other organisms within the community is
doing then is helping them out so it's
either making some sort of vitamin or
cofactor that they need and other
possibilities it's detoxifying something
so some iron oxidation metabolism is
making some reactive nitrogen species
like nitric oxide or nitrite and then
there are bacteria that can then use
those and detoxify those so that's
another possibility thank you
is it normal to have more than one
Rubisco in the same organism yeah there
are a lot of bacteria that have
multiple types of Rubisco and they they
just each have their own utility so the
like we see what scenario the one is
more highly effective when there's a
lower concentration of oxygen and a
higher concentration of co2 and the
other is there's not better when there's
less so they just each have their own
uses I I think there's one organism that
actually has four different mariscos
thank you so it looks like we have time
for one more question
what other inhibitors are reverse
electron transfer are out there that you
could try so there are there are other
inhibitors of the complex one
particularly so what some of the things
we'd like to try are using azide which
inhibits Keim's that it's a lot like
cyanide where it inhibits teams and
binds to them irreversibly and then
there are also ways we can actually
block the forward using zinc with the
reverse electron transfer
I actually remember yeah there there are
a couple more out there I'll try and get
back to that one maybe people even email
you about that um I would like to once I
would like to once again thank dr. Eddie
for his presentation I would also like
to thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December 13th
2018 you'll receive an email from
laberd's letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that is all for now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye